BREAKING NEWS OVERSEAS.
THREE AMERICANS HELD PRISONER
IN NORTH KOREA NORTH KOREA ARE
ON THEIR WAY HOME.
THEY WERE FREED TODAY AND
WALKED ON TO THE PLANE OF
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
AT END OF DAY LONG VISIT THAT
INCLUDED A MEETING WITH KIM
JONG-UN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SURPRISE
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR RELEASE.
>> RIGHT NOW, FLYING BACK ARE
THREE WHAT THEY WERE CALLING
HOINGT TAMS.
WE CALL THEM FINE PEOPLE THREE
REALLY FINE PEOPLE AND SEEMED
TO BE HEALTHY THEY'LL LAND
2:00 IN THE MORNING ANDREWS
AIR FORCE BASE AND I'LL BE
THERE TO GREET THEM NOBODY
THAT THIS WOULD HAPPEN AND IF
IT DID IT WOULD BE YEARS OR
DECADES FRANK LIMIT NOBODY
THOUGHT THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND I APPRECIATE KIM JONG-UN
DOING THIS.
>> AND THEIR RETURN CLEARS
THE WAY TO HISTORIC UPCOMING
SUMMIT BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND KIM JONG-UN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD NEWS
EARLIER ON WHEN THAT MEETING
WILL TAKE PLACE.
>> WE'LL ANNOUNCE THAT IN
THREE DAYS.
WITHIN THREE DAYS.
>> WITHIN THREE DAYS?
>> WITH IS WORK AGO
ARRANGEMENTS.
>> WILL IT BE IN THE DMV.
>> IT WILL NOT BE THERE.
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS CAN
HAPPEN AND A LOT OF BAD THINGS
CAN HAPPEN AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE BOTH SIDES WANT TO
NEGOTIATE A DEAL.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
VERY SUCCESSFUL DEAL.
>> GREG, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
NOT GOING TO GO TO THE MEETING
IF THE DETAINEES WERE STILL
BEING HELD BY NORTH KOREA
NORTH KOREAIANS THIS WAS A
SMART MOVE MOVE THAT THEY
REALLY WANT TO HAVE IT.
>> I THINK THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" SHOULD BE RELIEVED TO
KNOW WHERE POMPEO WAS.
THEY WERE LIKE WHERE IS POMPEO
WHY IS HE NOT HERE WITH THE
IRANIAN DEAL.
HE WAS DOING SOMETHING ELSE?
WE HAVE SARAH SANDERS ON TAPE
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
>> DI JUMP THE GUN.
>> IT'S A PERFECT SEGUE,
LET'S LISTEN TO THAT.
>> THE FACT I'M STANDING HERE
TAKING QUESTIONS AND THE FACT
PRESIDENT TOOK QUESTIONS FROM
YOUR COLLEAGUES TWO HOURS AGO.
DEMONSTRATES THIS WHITE
HOUSE'S COMMITMENT TO
ACCESSIBILITY TEEN PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
AT THE SAME TIME THE PRESS HAS
A RESPONSIBILITY TO PUT OUT
ACCURATE INFORMATION.
JUST YESTERDAY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" ACCUSED SECRETARY OF
STATE FOR BEING A WOL.
A WOL WHEN LE WAS PLAYING
ACROSS THE GLOBE TO BRING
THREE AMERICANS HOME.
THAT IS OUTRAGEOUS CLAIM.
>>, THERE SHE WAS MAKING YOUR
POINT.
>> YES, YOU KNOW I THINK THE
MEDIA MAY HAVE TO ADMIT
DESPITE THE LAWS OF TRUMP THEY
HAVE TO COVER ACCESSABLY ON
OTHER CHANNELS UNITS ELECTED A
PERSON WITH A UNIQUE SKILL SET
THAT IS GOOD FOR THESE EVENTS.
HE MAY NOBT WARD KLEVER OR
MARCUS WELLBY M.D. TRYING TO
HIT THE AUDIENCE.
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN.
>> BUT, HE HAS A SKILL SET
THAT PRESIDENTS PAST PRES MAY
NOT HAVE HAD AND IT'S TIME TO
MOVE ON AND KIND OF ACCEPT
THAT THIS IS WHAT HE MIGHT BE
GOOD AT AND GET OVER THE TWO
TWO-YEAR TANTRUM.
WE MAY NEEDANT EYE GRIEF
COUNSELOR IN THE MEDIA TO
CHEER THESE PEOPLE UP.
>> WELL, I JUST -- IT IS
INTERESTING THING.
YOU HAVE THIS HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY AND YOU WONDER IF
PEOPLE CAN GET OVER POLITICS.
POLITICS IS INFUSED IN
EVERYTHING WE DO AT ALL TIMES.
EVERYBODY CAN BE HAPPY THAT
THESE THREE ARE COMING HOME.
>> WAY YOU LOOK TAT YOU'RE
WELCOME FOR FIRE AND FEWER
YAIN FOR BLOODY NOSE APPROACH
AND MILITARY EXERCISE AND
YOU'RE WELCOME FOR ALL THE
FEAR AND CRAZINESS THAT
SO-CALLED MAINSTREAM MEDIA
HAVE.
HE'LL BRING US TO NUCLEAR
ARMAGEDDON HE'LL SCARE KIM
JONG-UN UNTIL HE COMES TO THE
TABLE AND MAKES ALL THESE
CONCESSIONS UP FRONT BEFORE WE
EVEN HAVE A TALK, WHICH SHOWS
HOW SERIOUS THEY ARE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY BELIEVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT ACTUALLY
TAKE AWAY NUCLEUSES OR BOMB
THEM IF NECESSARY.
THAT'S NECESSARY PREREQUISITE
FOR PEACE AND IT TAKES A
PERCEPTION OF CRAZY MAN AND
FWRINGZ TO THE TABLE TO BRING
PEACE.
>> WHAT'S A BEGEEBER.
>> MILITARY TORM.
>> NO A MID WESTERN SDMRERM
FOLLOWING FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
>> FOLLOWING IN GREG
FOOTSTEPS THE WHOLE DEMO THING
THING.
>> AND THE ONE I THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS WILL BE TO TAP
THE BRAKES ON PEOPLE GETTING A
LITTLE OVERLY EXUBERANT
THINKING WORLD PEACE IS AT
HAND AND NORTH KOREA NORTH
KOREA
NOREA
NORTA
NORTH KOREAIANS WILL BE DO
EVERYTHING ASKED TO THEM WHEN
THEY COME TO THE TABLE.
HE ALWAYS SAYS YOU HEARD HIM
RIGHT BEFORE WE STARTED THERE
WOULD BE A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
THAT HAPPEN AND BAD THINGS
THAT HAPPEN AND HE'S TRYING TO
SHOW EVERYONE HE'S AWARE NORTH
CORI COFFINIANS HAVE ATTENTION
FOR LYING.
>> I THINK EVERYBODY HAS HIGH
HOPES THAT THIS -- THOSE
PEOPLE ARE IN GOOD HEALTH.
OBVIOUSLY AUTO WARMBIER WAS
NOT IN GOOD HEALTH AND PEOPLE
DIDN'T THIS THINK COULD HAPPEN
DECADES -- THESE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN HELD SINCE '15 IS LONGEST
AND '17 FOR TWO PEOPLE COMING
HOME.
AND THANK GOD THIS IS
HAPPENING BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
NORTH KOREA NORTH KOREAIANS DO
NOT TREAT PRISONERS FAIR LIMIT
I THINK IT'S A CRAZY NARRATIVE
TO SAY IT'S BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP RHETORIC THAT
SOMEHOW YOU SEE THE NORTH
KOREA NORTH KOREAIANS SUDDENLY
ACTING MORE GRACIOUSLY.
I THINK THE FACT IS IT'S
SANCTIONS AND PRESSURE.
>> IT'S PART OF IT.
>> SEPTEMBER IT ALL PART OF
IT PRESSURE CHINA WITH
SANCTIONS.
>> WE'VE HAD SANCTIONS.
>> THESE ARE SANCTIONS ON
COMPANY
COMPANIES.
>> AND GETTING CHINA TO COME
ON BOARD.
>> AND EVEN WITH THAT THE
PRESIDENT, SOMEHOW, THINGS GET
STEPPED ON YOU KNOW?
SO YESTERDAY IT WAS THE IRAN
DEAL AND BY THE WAY "NEW YORK
TIMES" IN THEIR STORIES SAY
POMPEO WAS ON WAY TO NORTH
KOREA TO HOPEFULLY BRING HOME
THREE PEOPLE I DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU WANT TO PICK ON THE TIMES.
>> HEADLINE WAS DIFFERENT I
ONLY READ THE HEADLINES.
>> AND I DON'T HAVE TIME FOR
YOUR STORY
YOUR STORIES AND.
>> HE'S NOT CONTENT ORIENTED.
>> I'M A MINLIAL.
>> WITH THE PEOPLE.
>> THE PEOPLE MEANWHILE ALSO
RUSSIAN MONEY BEING FUNNELED
TO MICHAEL COHEN AND ON THE
GOOD NEWS ABOUT NORTH KOREA
NORTH KOREA AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS HERE AND IT'S LIKE
MAERINGT YOU HAVE TO KEEP YOUR
EYES ON BOTH HANDS.
HE'LL DISTRACT AND REFLECT AND
WAIT A SECOND WE'VE ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT HOW AMAZING THE
PRESIDENT'S ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ARE HERE AND CELEBRATING THE
FACT THESE THREE AMERICANS
CAME HOME GENE HEALTH,
PROSPERITY, INFORMATION.
>> AND WITH INFORMATION.
>> SO THIS IS SOMETHING WHEN
YOU LOOK AT TYPE OF DIP MROMCY
IT'S LIKE DESTABILIZING
DIPLOMACY HE ENGAGES IN.
IT'S NOT ANYTHING ANYONE HAS
SEEN BEFORE FOR SXEERNSZ AND
IT THROWS THE OTHER SIDE OVER
THE GAME AND THEY'RE NOT SURE
WHAT TO EXPECT OR AND AND
THAT'S THE SECRET TO HIS
SUCCESS AS IT RELATES TO
FOREIGN POLICY AND WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN TERMS OF HOW HE
HANDLED HIMSELF DIPLOMATICALLY
AND PAYING ATTENTION AND HE'S
LIABLE TO JUST DO ABOUT
ANYTHING.
AND HE STEPS ON GOOD NEWS AND
GHOR NEWS.
AND SO I THINK OF IT AS JUST
THE OPPOSITE.
I THINK HE WAS SAYING GOOD
NEWS IS LET ME JUST SAY THE
CRITICS HAVE BEEN ALL OVER
THIS ESPECIALLY DEMOCRATS.
FROM PRESIDENT OBAMA ALL THE
WAY.
>> I CAN INTERRUPT I HAVE A
LITTLE SOUND ON THAT.
>> GO RIGHT AHEAD YOU.
>> GUYS ARE SO GOOD AT MOVING
ME ALONG TODAY, PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS GETTING A LOT OF
HARSH CRITICISM FOR PULLING
OUT OF IRAN DEAL FOR LEADERS
NEGOTIATED AND OTHER POWERFUL
DEMOCRATS AND PRESIDENT OBAMA
WAS SAYING PULL-OFF RISKS
ERODING AMERICA'S CORRECT AND
JOHN CARRY SAYS BREAKS
AMERICA'S WORD AND NANCY
PELOSI SAID IT GLOBALS
SECURITY AND DEFIES
COMPREHENSION.
I'LL TURN TO YOU GREG ON THAT.
>> IF YOU'RE MAD ABOUT IRAN
YOU BLAME.
OBAMA WHO LEFT PARTY IN TATTER
WHICH ENABLED PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO BE ELECTED AND TWO PLAME
HILLARY WHO THOUGHT ELECTION
WAS IN THE BAG.
THEY ASSUME IT HAD HILL ANY
THERE AND PRESENTED LAST
SCANDAL AND PLAME HIM FOR
EVERYTHING.
>> IF YOU'RE MAD DON'T BE MAD
AT DONALD TRUMP.
AND LIKE A HANDSHAKE.
>> IT'S GREAT I LOVED -- I
CAN'T TELL WHO IS MORE
HYSTERICAL THE MEDIA, THE
DEMOCRATS OR THE IRANIANS
BURNING FLAGS.
I SAW HOW IRAN SUPREME LEADER
SAID TRUMP CORPS WILL BE WORM
FOOXTD I THINK HE'S
AUDITIONING FOR MORNING JOE.
THAT'S WHAT I HEAR ON MORNING
JOE.
>> THERE'S ONE SAYING PETE
I'LL TURN TO YOU ON THIS ABOUT
WHY YOU KNOW STATE DEPARTMENT
IN THE PERSON POLITICAL OWE
POINT HE WITH THE EUROPEANS
DIFFERENT AND TRY TO GET TO
SOMETHING THEY AGREE ON THE
SUNSET PROVISION ON THIS DEAL
ON OBAMA DEAL AND WITH SUNSET
AND SO.
>> IN TEN YEARS.
>> IRANIANS WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET NUCLEAR WEAPON RIGHT AFTER
THAT.
I'M CURIOUS YOU HAVE INSIGHT
TO WHAT IT WAS THE EUROPEANS
WERE SO RESISTANT ABOUT
CHANGING THAT SUNSET POSITION.
>> I THINK THEY'RE RESISTANT
CHANGING ANYTHING ON A DEAL
THEY FEEL INVESTED IN AND GEEL
ABOUT LEGACY THEY GOT AND
BARACK OBAMA GOT WHO IS THEIR
INTERNATIONAL FRIEND AND IT'S
DIFFICULT TO CHANGE A DEAL
LIKE THAT.
>> HE ALSO MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY KIM BETTER LIRKS THERE'S
A LOT OF ECONOMIC AK TICHTY
THAT'S WAS ALLOWED UNDER THIS
DEAL EUROPEANS IN PARTICULAR.
>> ABSOLUTELY YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID I
UNDERSTANDFY WERE THEM I WOULD
BE UPSET TOO.
HE HAS TO ASK IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE UNITED STATES
AND GLOBAL FUTURE AND NATIONAL
SECURITY AND SAFETY OF AMERICA
AND QUITE FRANKLY THE WORLD
THIS IS NOT A GOOD DEAL.
I WOULD SHIRT AT THE THOUGHT
THAT PRESIDENT WHO RESEARCHED
IT MET WITH PEOPLE AND
DISCUSSED IT AND DECIDED TO
MAKE THIS DECISION AND DEPOSIT
MAKE IT BECAUSE HE WAS AFRAID
OF CRITICISM AND PEOPLE WOULD
SAY NOW THAT WE'VE DONE --
YOU'VE TORN DOWN A LEGACY
PORTION OF BARACK OBAMA.
IT WAS NOT WELL THOUGHT OUT TO
BEGIN WITH AND PRESIDENT
SHOULD NOT STICK IN A BAD
DEAL.
THAT'S WHY HE ALSO PULLED OUT
OF THE PARIS CLIMATE CHANGE
ACCORD BECAUSE HE ANALYZED IT
AND DID NUMBERS AND AS I SAID
YESTERDAY I DO NOT THINK THAT
WE SHOULD, IN FACT, FUND A
NUCLEAR IRAN.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY WERE NOT
YOU KNOW HONEST AS IT RELATED
TO THEIR INSPECS OR ANYTHING
ELSE IS,SELF UP SUSPECTING AND
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
IT WAS NOT SOMETHING REALLY
GOOD FOR THE UNITED STATES FOR
QUITE FRANKLY THE WORLD.
CONCERN AND I STHAW IN THE
PAPERS TODAY, IS PRESIDENT
TRUMP ACTING IN THE INTEREST
OF THE UNITED STATES AS
OPPOSED TO SIMPLY BEING VIN
VINTICTIVE AND SAYING I DON'T
LIKE OBAMA AND PAST DEAL AND
THIS IS HORRIBLE AND I'M A
DEAL MAKER I CAN CREATE OKAY
OS AND COME TO THE TABLE ON MY
TERMS AND WAIT A SECOND, DOES
IT REALLY MAKE US MORE SECURE?
REMEMBER, TWICE THIS PRESIDENT
HAS CERTIFIED THAT IRAN DID
NOT VIOLATE ANY OF THE TERMS
OF THE DEAL.
>> EACH TIME.
>> THE EUROPEANS YOU --
>> WAITING LET ME PINISH,
AND INTERNATIONAL ATOMIC
ENERGY, NO EVERYDAY OF ANY
VIOLATION.
PRESIDENT SAYS YESTERDAY HE
DOESN'T HAVE -- INSTEAD HE
SAYS ROTTEN DEAL, HORRIBLE
DEAL.
I'LL GET A BETTER DEAL.
WHAT DO WE SEE RIGHT NOW.
WE SEE THE UNITED STATES
ISOLATED FROM ALLIES AND
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID REAL
CHOICE HERE IS NUCLEAR IRAN OR
WE GO TO WAR AND TAKE THEM
OUT.
HE HUG TODAY OUT.
>> WE STABLE LIDZING THE
MIDDLE EAST.
>> AND LOVES THE DEAL.
WE'RE NOT ISOLATED.
>> LAST WORD TO GREG.
>> AND YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS THE PATTERN THAT WE'VE
SEEN.
START -- HE COMES IN AND
CREATES CHAOS BY TURNING TABLE
OVER AND THAT TURNS TO A
CERTAIN KIND OF UNCERTAINTY SO
WHEN YOU START NEGOTIATE THE
OTHER SIDE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND LEFT THE DOOR
OPEN.
THIS IS EXACTLY -- WHAT I SEE
THIS AS KIND OF A REPLAY OF
NORTH KOREA AND NORTH KOREA
STARTS TO BEGIN WITH CHAOS AND
MEDIA AND DEM DEMOCRATS THIS
IS COMPLETE DEJA VUE.
WE WILL LIVE THROUGH THIS SIX
MONTHS AGO.
>> LET DHOYM A GOOD DEAL.
LET DMOYM A DEAL BASED ON
BENEFIT OF EXPERIENCE THAT
WHAT HE'S LEARNED FROM THIS
DEAL WHAT THEY THINK WORKS AND
DOESN'T WORK.
I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF YOU KNOW
IRAN SELF CERTIFYING SAYING
NOPE, NO VIOLATIONS HERE FROM
US.
WINK, WINK, WHILE THEY'RE
CONTINUING TO BUILD A NUCLEAR
IRAN.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE HERE.
LET THE PRESIDENT GO THROUGH
IT.
MAKE STRONG CHOICES.
BASED ON FACTS AND INFORMATION
AND HE DID WIN THE ELECTION
AND IT'S HISPREROGATIVE AND
THERE'S A TEAM IN PLACE TO
MAKE
TOKE
TO MAKE SOLID DECISIONS.
>> YOU WANT TO NEGOTIATE A
DEAL WITH NORTH KOREA, GUESS,
WHAT NUCLEAR DISARMMENT.
BUT WE STEPPED OUT OF DAY DEAL
AND EVERYBODY IN THE WORLTD
WILL NEGOTIATE A NEW DEAL WITH
IRAN.
IS SHOWS THE WORLD WE WANT A
REAL DEAL?
>> NOBODY SAYS IT WAS A BAD
DEAL EXCEPT PRESIDENT TRUMP